all right guys
bang bang i've got ryan here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
i'm stoked to be here absolutely let's
jump right into your background you've
built and sold two companies and now
working on your third
kind of walk us through your journey to
becoming a three-time
startup founder and ceo yeah uh
very first company got got started young
uh it was an online ad network
called banquet and basically we sold ads
on
other people's extreme sports websites
um and so that was as big of a business
as it sounds like
we were about a million dollars in
revenue uh when we got acquired it was
uh
sold in business to usa today sports on
new year's day 2008 i was uh
in my junior year at hofstra and uh
and barely graduated while you know
trying to work for a public company
uh and and finish my work there uh
stayed there for four years had a good
time uh
ultimately while i loved the ad business
uh
in some respects i just couldn't see
myself selling squares and rectangles on
web pages
for the rest of my life i left in 2012
with uh with my co-founder from that
company
a guy named rod davis moved to san
francisco started a company called swarm
it was a retail analytics platform for
small business retailers so we could
tell you foot traffic conversion sales
in a
in a web dashboard that was a slightly
better business
still really challenging we attempted to
build our own hardware which i would not
recommend to any founder
um but we ended up having a really great
outcome sold the business to groupon
in uh in november 2014. and uh
at that point i moved back to new york
uh rudd and i went our separate ways
he's
he and i are still you know best friends
he started a company though called uh
blackbird
um which was later acquired by sir fair
uh which will be going public soon uh
through his back so
um that worked out has worked out really
well for him uh i got back to new york
in 2016
and and started electric and so the the
premise for electric is pretty simple
we do manage i.t support for small and
mid-sized companies
but we sell it as a subscription sas
solution with some services
um so you know instead of having some
you know the old way of doing it right
some random
local dude i.t consultant who takes a
day to return your call
right if you work with electric we
integrate with slack and microsoft teams
you have a web-based dashboard
you have an awesome account manager so
we've really kind of modernized
it management so that business is doing
very well
we have about 250 employees raised about
60 million dollars we're doing kind of
mid
eight figures in uh in recurring revenue
and uh
yeah that's probably the fastest i've
run through my highlight reel
so i i'll turn it back to you explain
what it support is for those that don't
know
yeah well you know nowadays in in 2020
you know what what it means is
is basically three sort of major food
groups the first is sas management
right so you've got companies now the
average business we work with is about
100 employees
um and they're using anywhere from 50 to
75
different applications right 10 years
ago you might have used five right
um so just sas management doing that in
a really cohesive uh
efficient secure way that's a big
responsibility then it's device
management so
if you have 100 employees or even if you
have 20 employees or 200 employees
um you got to make sure that those
computers that you know where they are
that they're secure that they're running
correctly
um so we handle that and then the third
piece is uh network and server
management so if you have some physical
infrastructure
making sure that that's running
correctly that it's secure tie it all
together into sort of you know
one uh one cohesive easy to manage
solution so pretty straightforward
absolutely and one of the things that i
really appreciate about kind of the way
you approach
building companies is uh you are very
straightforward right so there's no kind
of [ __ ] here you're like look
uh you learn on the job it's really hard
if you're good at it then it can be very
rewarding but like
the celebritization of founding
companies and being a startup founder
uh doesn't tell the whole story and you
basically
through twitter and kind of a bunch of
different mediums explain like
here is what it takes to do this and
maybe sometimes you do it well and
sometimes you don't do it well but like
this is what it uh kind of entails where
does that
uh interest come from or like why are
you drawn to sharing that type of
information
i think because i was so bad at my job
for so long
i mean it's a good reason my my fir my
first two companies were just
were dumpster fires you know we ended up
having good outcomes but
every possible mistake i mean we were
talking about
fundamentally flawed business models
mixed with
the wrong talent at the wrong times
mixed with you know
me and and you know run and i win our
first two companies not knowing anything
about how to
you know manage the people worked for us
not knowing how to manage up to the
board
and so you know every day it wasn't a
question of like oh is today gonna be a
good day it was like
how many fires am i gonna have to
contend with
today and so you know it wasn't until
it wasn't until the tail end of my time
running swarm back in
like 2014 where i finally had been doing
this for so long and just screwing up
enough things
that it just sort of clicked that like
this
you know the sooner i can acknowledge
that i suck at a lot of things and the
sooner i can get really focused
on seeking out answers from people who
have done the things that i've done
before
like the better i'm going to get at the
job and the better i get at the job the
more fun i'm going to have
and the more successful the company is
going to be but it's just so hard
even if you if you think of yourself as
a relatively high eq person
it's so hard when you have when you have
all this confidence driving you as a
founder
to also admit that you really don't have
all the answers
uh and then in most cases you're
probably going to be wrong and that
you've got to turn to other people to
get the answers so
um once i saw the benefits of actually
just kind of embracing that mindset uh
all of a sudden i started learning
faster i started doing better my company
started doing better and so
to me it's just something i'm really
passionate about and like to talk about
absolutely so you've got this one tweet
where you said look here's the three
jobs of the ceo right you said
recruiting storytelling and awareness
maybe walk us through why are those the
three things that
you feel like are the most important to
focus on
yeah i mean it's it's cliche at this
point to to to point to the fact that
like oh the team is everything
but but it is right at the end of the
day like a software business
is a completely fictional concept right
like
we don't sell anything i don't have a
warehouse full of electric licenses
somewhere i don't happen to sell you
know what i mean like
end of the day like our company in
really any technology business
is just a collection of people who all
generally believe in the same thing and
agree to work on something together
right and so the quality of the company
you build is is entirely contingent on
the quality of the people and not just
the quality of the individuals but
can i can i hire a group of people who
are all going to work well
together right one of my one of my board
members tim harvey he you know he said
this to me it's like dude it took me
until my third time being ceo to realize
it's not about the best talent it's
about the best team and those two things
are not always the same thing and so you
know when i think back to my first
year my first two companies almost every
problem that we had almost every
business problem that we had
was actually a people problem right and
i see this all the time when
i get a founder who calls me and it's
like hey like i have a sales problem
and it's like no you have a you have a
people problem and the people problem is
that you actually
have a marketer who's not delivering any
leads and you have a product person
who's not shipping what the customers
want
sales are actually the least of your
worries right and so i think it's just
it can't be emphasized enough that the
only way you're ever going to build a
company that's that's really going to be
worth anything
is focusing on the people first focusing
on the team so
uh so that's the first one um the the
second one storytelling
you know as a as a founder and ceo at
every stage of the
of the journey you're only as good
as what you can get people to believe in
right
metrics are great but at the end of the
day if you're trying to secure financing
if you're trying to hire those great
people to come work for you if you're
trying to
get the story in front of the big
customer if you're trying to
explain you know internally what's going
on to sort of keep morale high
you have to become an expert at
distilling things that are extremely
complicated and frankly most of the time
not that interesting
and make them very simple and very
exciting it's it's not dissimilar to
like one of the core principles of uh of
pop
music and like writing pop music is
taking something
that's really unique and making it so
that everybody can understand it and
therefore
anybody can be a one-hit wonder as long
as people get what you're doing
i mean it's no different with
storytelling in a startup in fact it's
even more important like how can you
take
something as unsexy as i.t support and
get to a place where people are throwing
tens of millions of dollars at you and
leaving their jobs to work for you right
so and there's a skill to that but you
just have to do it a lot right
um and then the third piece which i
think makes the first two
uh work really well together is is
awareness you just have to have
um you have to get to a place where you
can be a spectator to your own thoughts
right so like every day you're gonna
have stuff that blows up
every day you're going to have people
mad at you every day you're going to
have things that you're you're
uncertain about but to be able to step
outside of yourself constantly and say
why like why am i feeling this way why
are things going this way like
am i doing a good job you can't you
can't let it get to a place where you
just go into some like tailspin of
anxiety i mean i've
i've been there as of probably most
people but
um you've got to constantly be able to
just just get to a place where you can
take a step back
and really ask yourself the tough
questions is this going well
am i being a jerk do i have the right
people on the team
um you know because ultimately like like
most businesses that wind up
being successful it's because they
avoided the things that killed them more
so than it was because they were really
brilliant and executed on a bunch of
amazing things absolutely and one of the
things that you
talked about a little bit there in
recruiting uh but you've elaborated on
is this idea that like
just as you can't out train a bad diet
you can't outwork bad people on the team
uh
talk a little bit about how i'm assuming
you learned that lesson
uh by experiencing it and then came to
the realization
but kind of how do you think about that
today yeah i mean everybody's been in a
situation particularly you know whether
you're a business owner or or you're a
manager of people or you're on a team
that's where you're working with
colleagues where
everyone at some point in their career
has been a situation where you're just
going in circles you're going in circles
you're in meetings everyone's talking
past each other
nobody can agree to goals you agree to
goals but you kind of know that no one's
ever going to hit them
and when those things start happening
almost always what that means is that is
that you've got the wrong person
on the team or maybe it's the wrong it's
the wrong people
and i think that the problem that a lot
of people have
i certainly had it was that
most people don't really know what
excellent looks like don't know what
world class really looks like
and so it's easy to to to be in a
situation where maybe you're managing
somebody
or your colleagues with someone and they
went to the right school they have all
the right experience from you know
some other company they worked at
they're a nice person seemingly right
and so that it's but you wake up six
months later and you're like we've got
nowhere on this initiative we've made no
progress
on this thing and you're just continuing
to go in circles it's like guess what
what's the common denominator
that person maybe that person's you
right i don't know but
um you know that's that's that's the
single biggest thing
and it where ceos often
make mistakes and and frankly nuke their
businesses
is that they have the wrong people on
the team and they either take too long
to realize that that's the root cause
or they know that that's the root cause
and they don't act
fast enough yeah one of the things um
that i think a lot of this
gets back to is like communication right
so it's the ceo communicating to people
people being able to communicate back to
the ceo
um and kind of horizontal and vertical
uh communication i remember
at facebook in 2014 when i was working
there
uh basically product managers interview
prospective product managers and they
kind of had this unique
hiring process and uh that year i said
hey i want to get much better at
interviewing so i just every time
there was an opportunity to do it i
would just volunteer and say hey i'll
interview that person
and uh in it one of the tracks
is uh basically like a um uh
a made-up situation like a war game
almost right so you would say to
somebody
hey ryan you're in charge of this team
here at facebook you go home on friday
everything's great monday morning you
come in and
traffic to your product has dropped 50
what do you do
right and basically you just talk
through them and kind of as they begin
to tell you what they would do you would
feed them more information
and i'll never forget that during that
exercise i probably did i don't know
somewhere between 80 to 100 interviews
um in uh doing this one person
said the first thing i would do is i
would immediately alert every
stakeholder that we had a problem
one person and i remember being like
this person
is the person that we need to hire
because they've done this before
they understand how important
communication is like they're team
oriented like just all the things you're
talking about
it was so interesting that only one out
of all of these people
jumped to let me communicate first
everyone else said let me solve the
problem let me jump in and try to figure
out
the answer uh and i think that that is
uh kind of the differentiation between
somebody who's high quality and then
somebody who may be good but they're not
kind of that world-class
highly experienced person i mean you're
totally right
i mean communication is is is the thing
that either makes or breaks most
relationships
business or you know personal right and
most people know that right and
and that's something that we've at least
an electric you know the way that we run
the company now is like
it we've acknowledged the fact that it
takes maintenance
it takes effort it takes you know i was
talking to my
my vp of product this morning and you
know we were
talking about the fact that yeah as an
executive team we all came together
um very organically everybody kind of
hit it off right off the gate
we did a bunch of hiring last year so we
basically doubled the size of our exact
team
uh about a year ago but one of the
things that we were talking about is
that
there's this tendency when you have
people who
already are very aligned and getting
along well and everyone's kind of
clicking
there's a tendency to actually under
invest in those relationships and say
hey you know what like
hey you know me and pop we get along
like we're all good we don't
we don't need to set aside all this time
we don't have to you know
it's the actually it's the opposite it's
that if you actually are lucky enough to
have that chemistry with your co-workers
or with your boss
or whatever those are the relationships
that you want to double down on and you
have to be really really intentional
about
cultivating trust and figuring out
everyone's you know kind of unique
communication styles and
and investing in the quality of those
relationships because
you're only going to get so far sort of
just getting there by accident or sort
of getting there
getting there organically and i mean
that's just where i've seen
just at other companies you know
otherwise very high performing
high potential individuals just go
sideways because of bad communication
and so
i think that'll be that'll be an issue
most humans have probably till the end
of time
but uh you know it's an important thing
to focus on because of that
we've talked a lot about kind of the
executive team communicating with each
other or also communicating with
employees
you mentioned earlier kind of managing
the board or managing up to the board
uh and talk a little bit about kind of
communication there
and most ceos especially first time
startup founders uh they've just never
had a board of directors before and so
kind of talk through a little bit about
the relationship between being a
founding ceo the board how you
communicate manage
uh kind of those outsider slash
investors yeah i mean look the board the
board is either going to be your biggest
asset
or at some point could wind up becoming
very problematic
you know most most vcs have been doing
this almost 15 years now like
most vcs really do want the founder to
succeed they want
everything to go well um and they really
want to have the founders back you know
fred wilson wrote a post recently about
you know when it's time to fire the ceo
i mean even he said look it's only in
you know pretty extreme circumstances
that that's
that's considered but but like anything
like what we were just talking about you
have to invest in those relationships
and so
one thing i did a really poor job with
uh i think in the early days of electric
and at my previous companies was like
i didn't really understand or respect
the fact that like
hey the board one they're ostensibly my
bosses
right so like you want to be
communicating with your bosses a lot too
you want to establish good relationships
but
but the third thing was like the the
more open
and transparent and queer and free the
communication is
the more trust you build every time an
email update goes out every time a text
message comes in
right and the more trust that's built
there the more productive those
relationships become so like in the
early days of electric
you know i would get an email from like
you know bob goodman at bessemer he'd be
like hey we should catch up and i'd be
like
oh [ __ ] oh no like bob wants to talk
then it's like
i'm just like one of a dozen portfolio
companies and he hasn't heard from me in
a while
he's curious what we've been up to right
and i would rush and try to put together
some big update and it would be like
this kind of awkward conversation and
i remember before we raised our series b
he you know he called me and he's like
he's like hey so he's like you know you
really got to step your game up you know
we're going to be bringing in some big
money for this next round and you know i
think you just really got to step up the
professionalism with how we
kind of manage things and you know once
jeff richards from ggb he let our series
be
a great podcast that you guys did by the
way a few weeks ago
um you know he came in and just kind of
used that as like an opportunity to sort
of turn over a new leaf and say all
right
everything good bad and ugly i'm going
to be clear i'm going to be concise
anytime i have news that is material to
the business it's boom it's going to go
to them
and it completely changed my
relationship with the board
you know i i send them updates almost
weekly they're not formal
um you know for example our professional
services group hit a big milestone on
sunday night i just forwarded the email
from the guy who runs that department of
the board and the board's like hey this
is awesome great thanks
a little bit of stuff like that every
single week by the time you get to the
board meeting everyone's like nah cool
like we know what's going on let's talk
about the strategy
right um but it's just so hard for a
first-time founder
i think and even some multi-time
founders to wrap their head around the
fact that like
you're bored they are your friends or at
least they want to be
okay so you just got to be honest and
you got to communicate often with them
one time somebody said to me the problem
with boards and startup founders
especially first-time founders who don't
yet understand how to use the board
is that founders look at the board as a
fundraising
fundraising mechanism right they look at
them as a potential problem solver
and then always looming over their
shoulder is the board could
fire me right or the board could be
adversarial in some way
and what he said is the thing that
people don't realize is like if you tell
others your problems the right people
will try to help you solve them
and who better to try to help you solve
your problems than the people who are
financially aligned with seeing you
succeed
like that's the key just continue to
communicate good bad or ugly to them and
they will help you
yeah like in some ways you know i kind
of like look at part i mean
ultimately i'm responsible for
everything good or bad that happens in
the business and i take that
responsibility very seriously but
there's a part of the startup ceo where
in some ways you're also a little bit
more of like the weatherman
in the sense that it's like it's also
just your job to sort of report
stuff and have a dialogue about why it's
gonna rain on tuesday
not like thinking oh they're gonna yell
at me because it's gonna rain on tuesday
like it is what it is you just have to
be able to have the dialogue and like
actually jeff richards is a really good
example of somebody who
you know believes in that but actually
um you know
really embodies that as a board member
you know we we right after he invested
we
we hit a little bit of a rough patch
with with the business and there was
some stuff that we needed to fix and i
called them and i was just like dude
i think we got to take some growth
projections down a little bit i think we
got to make some staff changes like i
know this is
a little sudden after you know we got
the deal done he's like he's like dude i
don't care
he's like i'm what i care about is the
next five years not the next five months
and he's like i'm just glad you're
calling and telling me now
not six months from now or a year from
now we got a much bigger problem on our
hands
you know um and it's like what ends up
happening and the advice i would give a
lot of founders is like
i can't tell you the feeling of relief
that will wash over you
when you have the hard conversation
because it's never as hard as you think
it's gonna be
and you're gonna walk out of your office
that night going wow oh man
like now that's off my chest we can
actually start solving the problem
yeah i wish i had that conversation six
months ago or three months ago
yeah well you know what i saw because
when i was at usa today and when i was
at groupon you know both were public
companies in the midst of
you know pretty colorful uh turnarounds
right and so
i think part of what gave me the the
motivation to be more proactive on
having the hard conversations at
electric was
living through you know two turnarounds
at public companies and watching what
happens if you just
bury problems forever and ever and ever
it's like guess what then someone who's
not you is going to come in
and flip the lights on and start
rummaging around in your business and
start telling you how to make the
sausage
and usually that ends up with you not
having a job anymore so
uh and it's entirely avoidable
absolutely
you talked a little bit earlier about
when you have the wrong people
uh being able to kind of get rid of them
and get the right people in there
one of the things that i've seen in
founder after founder after founder that
is very hard for them to get comfortable
doing is firing people
talk a little bit just about kind of
your own experience with having to
fire people and kind of how you've
gotten more comfortable with it over
time
yeah i mean look it sucks and everybody
at some point in their career goes from
having never fired someone
to having to let somebody go uh for the
first time and you know i remember
uh yeah back at my first company right
after we got acquired by usa today we
had a guy in the team who i was always
complaining about i just didn't think
was the right fit
and uh and so i reported to my
co-founder rudd because he became the gm
of the group once we we got acquired
and uh he ended up getting promoted i
became the gm and he's like
first order of business you got to let
go of that guy you've been complaining
about for the last three
months i never fired anybody before i
was i mean i was i i
wanted to call out sick for the whole
week so so i went home
and i watched uh hard knocks on hbo
because you know what i found was that
these nfl coaches are really good at
letting people go you know because they
have to release like half the squad you
know before the season starts or
whatever and so i just watched a bunch
of hard knocks episodes and i was like
okay
like you just got to be you got to be
direct you got to sit down you just got
kind of got to do the thing
um so whatever so i got through it and
it ended up um
ended up being fine but but sort of fast
forward to today
the the biggest thing that that we've
realized is that you're never gonna bat
a thousand you're never gonna hire
always make the best hires the key is
being really clear in the expectations
in the first you know
months two months and figuring out as
soon as possible
and then you know what i always tell the
company is that all attrition is
regrettable
right if we realize that we've that
we've hired somebody and they're not
living up to the standard that we that
that we want at the business
that's our fault we shouldn't have hired
them and we should have figured that out
before we extended them an offer before
they left their job before they came
over here right
and so so that's always been my stance
at the team here is like
it's always our responsibility if
someone's not a fit
and so and we have to treat it as such
and so as a result
one we're really clear about
expectations so that
it's it's not a surprise though no
matter how hard you tried it always is
for some people
and then the second thing is we try to
be pretty generous with uh
with severance more so than one might be
for somebody who might have only worked
at your company for a month just because
it's our responsibility you know we're
half the reason that we ended up in that
situation and so i think if you can
if you're clear with people and you're a
real like a decent human being about it
send the message to the rest of the org
into that person wherever they end up
next that
you know that you're the kind of company
that cares about people absolutely
one of the things i'm really interested
in is uh as you guys continue to build
electric and you're providing this it
support
uh you've got all the internal
challenges and of just kind of being the
ceo running a business growing it
uh but there's also uh some challenges
that your customer base has experienced
with the covid19
uh pandemic the economic shutdown talk a
little bit just about how
you've been able to balance dealing with
your internal just scaling
uh obstacles that every businesses uh
kind of goes through but also then
having at the same time
uh your customer base go through just
changes right some of it
some of your businesses may actually be
uh benefiting from it some of it may be
uh being hurt by it but just how have
you guys thought through that or how to
deal with that
yeah well i'll tell you what what's been
really interesting is that the more
internally focused we get in terms of
hiring great people taking care of them
you know fostering really productive
dialogues around tough issues
makes us better when with how we deal
with our customers right and and so i'll
sort of explain that but
you know if you think about if there was
ever a year to sort of like earn your
stripes as a
as a ceo like this this was definitely
one of them you know between
between cobin between you know a lot of
the things that are happening you know
socially
and politically and what's different now
versus
you know even five years ago is there's
a much different expectation
put on ceos particularly startup ceos
around their stance and their voice and
their involvement
in these things that are that you know
that are that are happening in the world
and so
i think the the challenges that i've
seen other companies run into
or that you know these founders and ceos
get so paralyzed
over you know being afraid to say the
wrong thing
that they either wait too long they say
nothing or they don't really say
anything at all
right they issue some bland statement
that was run through marketing or
whatever
and at the end of the day as i said
before it's like companies are our
collection of people
right and so what what what the
employees want and ultimately what your
customers want
is they want to hear from you the human
being
they don't want to hear from you the
venture-backed ceo
who's watching every single word now
obviously you have to
exercise some discretion but for example
you know
back in the beginning of june or that
last weekend in may um
you know when when there were you know a
lot of the protests started happening in
you know across america
yeah it was saturday afternoon i was
standing in my kitchen and i was like
i was like [ __ ] like i don't know i have
to address this
we have a very diverse um you know group
of employees here like what do i say
what do i you know
and finally i just like god i'm standing
in my kitchen and get on my phone
and the first thing i said in the email
was
i haven't sent this email yet because i
was afraid that i was going to say the
wrong thing or that it was going to come
off disingenuous like i literally just i
opened the email with that just to let
everyone working here know like i don't
really know
but here's how i feel and i'm just going
to put some words down on paper and the
response was amazing people were like
i'm just glad you said something i'm
glad you spoke from the heart and so
you know in contrast i i'm on a bunch of
ceo
like email threads and stuff i saw a lot
of companies just get
smoked because the ceo would hide in a
room with their head of hr for a week
saying nothing
and it's like i think when in doubt you
just got to default to uh
you know you got to think of your
employees almost as if they're an
extension of your friends or your family
and it's like what would you say on a
phone call with
a sibling or a friend right kind of
treat it like that don't overthink it
yeah and i also think that this idea of
setting expectations is really important
as well like
by simply saying like hey i haven't sent
this because
i've been scared of saying the wrong
thing like you're taking ownership of
the fact that like
here's why this hasn't gone out yet and
two by the way here's my vulnerability
so if i say the wrong thing like i was
already worried about that
right and it almost is in some weird way
uh when you tell people
uh especially in communication the
vulnerability it seems like they
immediately become much more empathetic
in the way that they kind of
receive the message and also they're
much more understanding if
uh maybe they disagree with you right or
they they have a different viewpoint
um it's just like hey look ryan's doing
the best he can with the information he
has and like
so am i and we may not see eye to eye on
especially
really polarizing controversial topics
but i appreciate the fact that the
person who's leading the company i work
at
has the courage to say what he believes
how he believes it
and kind of help us all move forward
together right 100 i mean look
everybody i think about this all the
time like every person on the planet
has some battle they're quietly fighting
some more publicly than others but like
everybody's got something
inside that's not going well some
vulnerability whatever and so
you know i think as a leader as long as
you can just show people that like
you're just like them too i i think it
gives you a lot more leeway in terms of
um
you know not not it sort of defuses any
tension that might be there people just
look at you like a human i mean we did
i sent a note out yesterday um you know
ahead of the election i basically
you know what i opened it with was like
listen i have no unique point of view on
politics or election law or anything
like that okay
but here's a few things that are purely
fact-based that i think we should all
take into consideration you know and i
think and the
note went over well because ultimately i
was just saying like i'm not an expert
on this
but like just here's some facts just so
that we can all you know kind of align
on a few things and and
that type of stuff goes over well with
people absolutely
one of the things i've been really
interested in too is uh and we will
close on this
is just as the ceo of a business there's
lots of social issues now there's
obviously the election kind of
uncertainty
there's just a lot of non-business uh
activities that are going on and you
know i always joke and say that
um if companies were purely capitalistic
in nature and they didn't worry about
anything else other than optimizing
profits
then there would be no politics in the
work a place there'd be no social issues
that you'd ever have to deal with like
it would just be machines basically
right every company would just have like
none of the other things that they have
to consider obviously though these
companies
are made up of people as we've been
talking about and so those people have
political ideologies they have certain
uh positions on social issues
we've seen ceos kind of take a couple of
different approaches some ceos say hey
look we want
you to express your opinion here we want
you to kind of feel comfortable having
every conversation you'd possibly want
we've also seen the other end of the
spectrum
um you know kind of the coin based
approach of like hey we are mission
focused company
and uh there's no room for politics in
the workplace how do you
maybe not so much just like which end of
the spectrum are you on but just how do
you think
through um the aspect of like the people
who work here
have other interests other than just
coming to work here every day and
operating like a robot
and how are we going to um kind of
deal with that along with trying to
build the company yeah
well okay so i think the first the the
first thing
and just sort of going back to sort of
the early stages of
of company building is the most
overlooked hire
in every startup is a great head of
people
right and why it's a combination of hr
and talent right so so we hired a vp of
people uh jamie coakley a couple years
ago
and i can't tell you how big of an
unlock that is for me as a ceo for the
rest of our leadership team
to have somebody if we all believe that
a company's his collection of people
to have somebody whose sole focus is is
to just look after
sort of the health and well-being of
this group of people right
um it's just companies wait wait i mean
we waited too long but we nailed it and
it really you know nailed the higher and
ultimately got around to it but
companies wait wait too long and the
reality is like if if you believe that
the people side of the business is that
important you just you have to invest in
having somebody to sort of run that so
that's that's a huge thing that most
companies overlook that you just you got
to you got to get it dialed in the
second piece is
what what i always try to get people to
understand and what we really believe in
here
is that using the company as a force for
good
is inherently a competitive advantage
and a force for good so
i don't care you know how uh
you know sort of how rigorous your like
moral compass is at the end of the day
if all you are is just a purely
capitalist profit driven person
it's still better business to be a good
human and to be
inclusive and to have a diverse you know
team and a diversity of opinions and so
you know for us i think when um you know
back in you know june july when a lot of
companies were announcing like
oh we've donated a hundred thousand
dollars to the aclu or we did this we
did that hey look that's fine
that's those are all those are all
really good causes but
internally we looked at it we said our
payroll is going to be 35 million
dollars next year
if we can can make our recruiting
processes
even a little bit more diverse a little
bit more inclusive
i have a 35 million dollar money cannon
that can actually create real change in
real communities right
and so um you know in in the sort of
follow-on effects that that has in terms
of the company culture that you build on
productivity
all that stuff um it's all very obvious
you know salesforce is a great example
of a company who i think
really led the way on this um you know
mark with his like one one one kind of
pledge approach
and i can't tell you the number of of
salesforce executives who have spoken
with over the years we're like
that's a big reason they went there and
it's a big reason they stuck around so
um you know i don't know if that
directly answered the question but
we've tried to orient the company really
around that as like how do we use the
whole thing as a force for good
um and then and then in return you know
we have
a diversity of employees who all have
different opinions and different things
that they care about but look at the end
of the day they recognize that we're
trying to do good
in running this company and as long as
their opinions and their interests don't
don't hurt anyone um then then that's
what diversity is all about we support
it
yeah what's so interesting about your
answer is it really highlights just the
complexity of all this there is no black
or white answer right there is no kind
of single magic bullet of like hey
here's the pot
the position to take and if you take
that position then
it's gonna solve all your problems like
there is complexity and that's
ultimately uh a net positive if used the
correct way
so i think that makes a lot of sense um
i always wrap up every interview with
the same two questions and then you'll
get to ask me one question to finish it
uh the first question is what is the
most important book you've ever read
it's interesting it's gonna be
a less shallow answer than it probably
sounds like but uh
when i was in high school i used to walk
around with a copy of barbarians at the
gate
and i probably read it five times and it
was i think
you know i i hadn't i was just in the
early days of starting a business but
it just it was so colorful and and so
fascinating reading about these crazy
you know leveraged buyouts and all this
stuff which i had no
you know didn't know anything about that
stuff at the time but like me as a high
school kid realizing that like yo this
is
this is business or like you know it
just
it just opened my eyes to just you know
what you know kind of what was possible
and just how gnarly things were and so
i mean i've read plenty of books that
are that are much more impactful
you know uh professionally i'm i'm
staring at a copy of
tape sucks which is frank slootman's
book which is awesome i've already read
it twice
but no barbarians at the gate i think
because i read it as a 16 year old was
uh hugely influential it's a great book
and uh tape sucks is another good one so
there's two good suggestions
uh what about the second question which
is more fun
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
i think big time i mean come on you
can't
you can't you just you just look at the
data statistically there has to be alien
life it's so we had a
our in one of our weekly exec team
meetings we went off on a tangent for 10
minutes
at the beginning of our meeting and we
like genuinely debated it i think we
we all came to the conclusion like there
are for sure aliens out there
and maybe it's like some worm on some
you know moon
outside of some random planet or maybe
it's intelligent life
but it's definitely out there yeah i
tend to agree with you but we'll uh
we'll we'll see there's some deep signal
coming from the galaxy supposedly i was
reading this morning
so we'll we'll see what's going on there
you could ask me one question to uh to
wrap us up what do you got for me well
yeah seeing as how your your listeners
are uh
or a lot of folks who are kind of
hobbyist investors in in one way shape
or form or
or another what's uh what's one
trend whether it's it's a trend in asset
class
an individual company though you
probably don't want to be given stock
tips
on air but uh what's what's one thing if
you uh
you know if you had to place a bet that
you think is an overlooked bet
uh for 2021 for people who are investing
what would it be
yeah so i don't know if there's
necessarily one there's probably just a
theme
and the theme that i always talk about
is like the fringe of society
so right now if you said to me like what
are the things on the fringe of society
that
uh maybe like your weird friend is into
right it's kind of the way i think about
it like that one weird friend who you're
you can't figure out like are they just
weird or are they actually smart and
just
thinking about different things but like
okay so
space psychedelics cryptocurrency
right i mean like that's all the things
that everyone's got that friend who's
always like
on the tip of the spear of like the
weird stuff well
what we found is that weird stuff
usually makes its way into the
mainstream right or some good percentage
of it
and so just take the three things i just
named there like space
now's not weird like now everyone's like
yeah of course like space is going to
become much more popular
10 15 years ago like that was kind of
fringe like you're telling me you're
gonna like launch a rocket and then
re-land it that was a
crazy idea i think uh cryptocurrency
maybe like
five years ago was super french i'm
literally having flashbacks to being at
zac
prince's apartment in 2016 and he takes
a sip of his
of his drake and he's like jenny have
you been buying any bitcoin
and i'm like you're nuts you're crazy
right so like five years ago crypto was
like super fringe
you have that one friend jack prince who
ends up going to build block five right
who's like kind of like out there now i
think like uh
psychedelics is a huge place right
although like the uh drug
decriminalization that's happening like
there's just a whole area there that
like i frankly don't
understand really well enough there's a
great great company called mind bloom uh
another friend of mine
similar similar to the to the zak prince
story but a few years later
my buddy dylan he goes hey i'm starting
this company it's uh it's ketamine
therapy
and i was like you're nuts you're gonna
get vcs to give you money to send people
ketamine in the mail
and you know i'm already regretting not
investing so i think you're totally
right with this recommendation
yeah and so like the reason why i say
it's a theme more so than just like one
asset class if you will or one kind of
industry
is okay we just identified three there's
probably ten
more that like that one friend is
already thinking about that just hasn't
seeped enough into like the mainstream
for like me to know about yet
well think about like esports right like
there's gonna be a professional gaming
league i think for world of warcraft
10 years ago we were like no
[Laughter]
absolutely and if you again uh play vs
right if you look at like what delane's
built there oh yeah
they basically built an entire national
system uh that mirrors the ncaa
right but for gaming across all these
schools and so it's just
i think that a lot about like investors
are rewarded for
one being early and two being right and
a lot of times when you're early that
means you have to do something different
than everybody else
and so like sure are there people that
will spend all of their time trying to
figure out
you know is starbucks current uh revenue
multiple
too high or too low and what's the
future earnings uh based on
you know their rollout plan and their
and their international expansion and
like
sure and there's people who are good at
that that's not me right
and that's not where my interest lies
instead my interest is much more in like
what's that next thing that people are
going to be talking about in five years
that they're like wow remember when i
was talking to ryan and ryan mentioned
to me like this thing and i thought he
was crazy
well now it became a thing i mean i
remember when i had you know my my best
my best performing seed investment to
date has been a company called stadium
goods
um these guys raised less than 10
million dollars sold for 250 million
dollars to farfetch that stock is now
ripping
uh was awesome outcome for everybody but
i remember in 2015
when they started the company you know
and i was trying to make interest to
investors for for gen john and
people were like oh i don't know like
are people going to care about sneakers
particularly like used ones this and
then it's like streetwear literally is
is the next wave of high fashion for you
know millennials and gen z and it's like
so yeah i don't know i feel like if i
could if i could sum up this this this
whole podcast
that my two big takeaways are be a good
human
and bet on the fringes that is a
a fantastic way to uh to wrap this up
where can people find you on the
internet or
or find out more about electric yeah so
the best thing is
uh if anything i said about electric
sounds interesting just go to electric
dot ai
and uh if you want to find me on social
i am at
dennehy xxl on all platforms
awesome man listen thank you so much for
doing this i think people are really
going to like this one and hopefully
people will have a bunch of takeaways so
i'll do it again in the future yeah
looking forward to it thanks